monsieur ben ping pong sur la base de
ces preuves irréfutables du dopage de
monsieur plaza pouvez vous nous
confirmer que nous pouvons déclarer
annulé annulé le match qui s'est déroulé
hier soir
tout à fait je valide ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer que dans ces conditions
cyril hanouna peut reprendre la
présentation de l'émission tout à fait
il peut du tout de suite au matteo je
vais te donner un bon secret pour avoir
les miches bien ferme
il faut les pétrir les yeux fermés et we
do mais c'est la seule émission il ya
des cadreurs vous ferez à regarder ce
qui fait l'homme et je vais le montrer
parce que l'art et je montrais le gars
mais regarde ce qu'il fait et il est
comme ça sont il est comme ça commence
on est la seule émission où les cadeaux
arrivent à se cacher ou faire quoi sur
tmc dans un documentaire